our gut microbiome consists of 39  trillion microbial cells  whenever we consume antibiotic  it kills the pathogenic bacteria but  along with that it kills the good  bacteria as well  that's pretty bad we need these good  bacteria for our health is there a way  to protect it scientists at mit has  devised a new bacteria which can  colonize with this good microbiota  they produce  antibiotic resistant substances which  would be protective for the good  microbiome but they would not protect  the bad bacteria or the pathogenic  bacteria so antibiotic will selectively  kill the pathogenic bacteria and the  good microbiome will be protected  thereby our gut microbiome can live  happily ever after that's one minute see  you in next video